This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Last October, the mayor of LA, Eric Garcetti, gave a speech about one of the biggest issues facing his city. It's just way too hot. We know that climate change is not an abstract crisis. This is the fight of our lives. Mayor Eric Garcetti in South Los Angeles today rolling out key elements of his cool streets program. This is the first of five neighborhoods across the city where we're rolling out new features that'll help us lower our temperatures.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马斯。去年十月，洛杉矶市长埃里克·加尔西蒂发表了一场演讲，谈到了他的城市面临的最大问题之一。天气实在太热了。我们知道气候变化并不是抽象的危机。这是我们生死攸关的战斗。市长埃里克·加尔西蒂今天在南洛杉矶推出了他的“清凉街道”计划的关键部分。这是我们在全市推出新设施以帮助我们降低温度的五个街区中的第一个。
The city is trying lots of things to cool down temperatures, like painting sidewalks white, but the easiest way to solve this problem is shade. Just creating shade, lots of neighborhoods in LA, don't have tree coverage or high-rise buildings and because of city bylaws it's really difficult to build features like shade sales or canopies. Dirtless Sandblock has spent a lot of time looking into shade, so I sat down to talk with them about why shade is actually a matter of life or death for people living in really sunny places.
这座城市正在尝试各种方法来降低气温，比如把人行道漆成白色，但解决这个问题最简单的方法就是遮阴。只需制造阴影，洛杉矶的许多街区就没有树木覆盖或高层建筑，而且由于城市规章制度，建造遮阳帆或遮阳篷等设施非常困难。Dirtless Sandblock 花了大量时间研究阴影，所以我坐下来与他们交谈，探讨为什么阴影对于生活在阳光非常充足的地方的人来说实际上是一个生死攸关的问题。
for people living in really sunny places. So you used to live in Los Angeles, and what did you notice about Los Angeles when you started walking around the city? What did I notice? I noticed that there was no one around. I noticed that the people who were around would have to position themselves in such a way to protect themselves from the sunlight.
对于生活在阳光非常充足的地方的人来说。所以你以前住在洛杉矶，当你开始在城市里四处走动时，你对洛杉矶有什么看法？我注意到了什么？我注意到周围一个人也没有。我注意到周围的人不得不以某种方式调整自己的位置，以保护自己免受阳光照射。
What do you mean? I noticed people waiting for the buses behind telephone poles. I notice people waiting for the buses behind telephone poles. I notice people waiting behind the people waiting behind telephone poles because there's only that small sliver of shade that people were protected from the sunlight. Why is shade so important?
你是什么意思？我注意到人们在电线杆后面等公交车。我注意到人们在电线杆后面等公交车。我注意到人们在电线杆后面等待的人后面等待，因为只有那一小片阴影能让人免受阳光照射。为什么阴影如此重要？
Los Angeles, like most every city in the world, is heating up. There are some scientists who I speak to who have found that in hot, dry, arid environments like Los Angeles, but also Phoenix, that shade is the most important factor when it comes to human comfort. More than air temperature, more than humidity, more than wind speed. And there's a close relationship between human thermal comfort and mortality and illness and
洛杉矶和世界上几乎所有城市一样，正在变暖。我交谈过的一些科学家发现，在洛杉矶以及菲尼克斯这样炎热、干燥、干旱的环境中，阴影是决定人体舒适度的最重要因素。比气温更重要，比湿度更重要，比风速更重要。人体热舒适度与死亡率、疾病以及
heat stroke. If you don't have shade, if you're not protective from the sun, you can, oh, you can become dizzy, you can become disoriented, you can become confused, a thargic, dehydrated. If you are obese or elderly or pregnant, that can tip into more dangerous things like heart attack or organ failure. And so what is the magnitude of the problem in L.A. There are a few different ways of thinking about it. We can talk about shade in terms of tree canopy, which is a very serious problem. Los Angeles has terribly unequal tree canopy.
中暑之间有着密切的关系。如果你没有阴影，如果你没有防晒保护，你可能会，哦，你可能会感到头晕，你可能会迷失方向，你可能会感到困惑、嗜眠、脱水。如果你肥胖、年老或怀孕，这可能会演变成更危险的事情，比如心脏病发作或器官衰竭。那么洛杉矶的问题有多严重呢？有几种不同的思考方式。我们可以从树冠的角度来谈论阴影，这是一个非常严重的问题。洛杉矶的树冠分布极其不均。
And by tree canopy, I just mean coverage. Like say you're not our space, looking down on LA. You'll see parts of the city that are covered in green. And you'll see parts of the city that are not. They're baking an asphalt. And those two aty follow lines of wealth. It's a problem with tree canopy, it's a problem in terms of the built urban form,
说到树冠，我指的就是覆盖率。比如，假设你不在太空中俯瞰洛杉矶。你会看到城市的某些地方被绿色覆盖。你会看到城市的某些地方没有。它们在沥青上烘烤。这两者遵循财富的轨迹。这是一个树冠的问题，也是一个城市建成形态的问题，
Los Angeles is notoriously anti-density, Los Angeles has this image of itself as not being New York City, in fact being the anti-New York City. So sunlight and open space is a part of the culture. That's not necessarily a problem, but it becomes a problem when you can't escape it. Right. So there are no tall buildings to provide some measure of shade. I wouldn't go as far as to say there are no tall buildings. However, there are a few
洛杉矶臭名昭著地反对高密度，洛杉矶给自己的形象不是纽约市，事实上它是反纽约市的。因此，阳光和开放空间是文化的一部分。这不一定是问题，但当你无法逃避它时，这就成了问题。没错。所以没有高楼大厦来提供一定程度的阴影。我不会走那么远说没有高楼大厦。然而，有一些
tall buildings. And there's space pretty far apart. Correct. They're located in certain height districts downtown being one of them. And even some areas that city planners have designated to be taller neighborhoods, even today, they're still fought and contested by neighborhood activists. So I've seen all pictures, and I get a sense that Los Angeles used to be greener, like there was a lot of shade.
高楼大厦。而且它们之间相距甚远。没错。它们位于市中心等特定的高度区域。甚至连城市规划者指定为更高街区的某些区域，直到今天，仍然受到社区积极分子的争论和抗争。所以我看过老照片，我有一种感觉，洛杉矶过去更绿，有很多树荫。
So tell me how the city was designed and how it developed into this. So time was Los Angeles was a prairie. If you look at photos of LA from 150 years ago, it's all grasslands. it developed into this. So time was Los Angeles was a prairie. If you look at photos of LA from 150 years ago, it's all grasslands. And when it was settled by the Spanish downtown, which was the original settlement, was laid out according to the law of the Indies. The city would roughly conform to a 45 degree angle, so you could have sunlight in the winter
所以告诉我这座城市是如何设计的，以及它是如何发展成这样的。曾几何时，洛杉矶是一个大草原。如果你看 150 年前洛杉矶的照片，全都是草原。它是如何发展成这样的。曾几何时，洛杉矶是一个大草原。如果你看 150 年前洛杉矶的照片，全都是草原。当西班牙人定居时，市中心作为最初的定居点，是按照印度法律规划的。这座城市大致呈 45 度角，这样你就可以在冬天享受到阳光
and shade and shadow in the summer. So what, to explain the law of the Indies, what does this mean? The law of the Indies means build your cities at 45 degrees, basically. Really? Completely unlike the way we think of most American cities, which have this sort of north, south, east, west, very rich, grid.
夏天有树荫和阴影。那么，解释一下《印度法》，这到底意味着什么？《印度法》基本上意味着将你的城市建造成 45 度角。真的吗？这与我们对大多数美国城市的看法完全不同，美国城市的这种南北、东西走向的网格非常丰富。
So you have these original settlements that are laid out in such a way as to be able to create shadow when you need it and also to bestow sunlight, also when you need it. Spanish architecture tends to have a very strong sense of natural comfort. So you'll see a lot of these kinds of missions and adobe that have these internal court yards that are shaded. You'll have covered walkways, paseos, and even today you'll see a lot of this and Spanish
所以这些最初的定居点采用这种方式布局，以便在需要时能够创造阴影，同时也能在需要时给予阳光。西班牙建筑往往对自然舒适度有着非常强烈的感知。所以你会看到很多这样的传教所和土坯房，它们有带阴影的内部庭院。你会看到有屋顶的人行道、步行街，甚至今天你仍然会看到很多这样的西班牙
revival architecture or, you know, outdoor malls that have goofy Spanish-ish names. Well, as the angelist was also in a way sort of a dusty old west town. So you think about these covered boardwalks, you think about large canvas awnings that are cooling people who are living outside and also cooling indoors, which at the time didn't have air conditioning. And another way that Los Angeles tried to stay cool was through rich, beautiful, kind of flamboyant, not just tree canopy, but a syncretic, overwhelming variety of exotic, fluorin phantom. So during this period, there was a recognition of the environment and how to be
复兴风格的建筑，或者你知道的，带有愚蠢的西班牙风格名字的户外购物中心。嗯，安吉利斯人在某种程度上也是一个尘土飞扬的旧西部小镇。所以你想想这些带屋顶的木板路，想想那些为生活在户外的人降温、同时也为室内降温的大型帆布遮阳篷，当时室内还没有空调。洛杉矶试图保持凉爽的另一种方式是通过丰富、美丽、某种程度上艳丽的树冠，不仅如此，还有各种各样异国情调的植物，令人眼花缭乱。所以在这一时期，人们认识到了环境以及如何在其中保持
comfortable inside of it. And when did that go wrong? Funny that you put it that way. Things started to go wrong after cheap electricity came down to Los Angeles with the completion of what's now called the Hoover Dam. So you start to see the city rebuild itself and the new development becomes like we see today. You have controlled air conditioning, you have the automobile which comes to dominate the city in the 30s and the 40s.
舒适。那是什么时候开始出问题的呢？真巧，你这么说。在廉价电力随着现在被称为胡佛大坝的建成而来到洛杉矶后，事情开始出问题了。所以你开始看到这座城市重建自己，新的发展变得像我们今天看到的一样。你有受控的空调，你在 30 年代和 40 年代迎来了主导这座城市的汽车。
And with the automobile you just have a whole new way to see the city. The names of the streets are as whole words translated into magic. Fabulous stacks of freeways tremendous turnpike. The city started to think about how to market itself and how to make itself see more tracted outsideers and this is where you get palm trees. Palm trees, one essayist said, were about as useful for shade as a telephone pole. She hated them, but the city was enamored of them. And interestingly, you have different philanthropist
有了汽车，你就有了一种全新的方式来看待这座城市。街道的名字就像被翻译成魔法的完整单词。神话般的交叉路口，巨大的高速公路。这座城市开始思考如何营销自己，如何让自己看到更多吸引外地人的地方，这就是你得到棕榈树的原因。一位散文家说，棕榈树对于遮阴的作用就像一根电线杆一样大。她讨厌它们，但这座城市却对它们着迷。有趣的是，你有不同的慈善家
and celebrities starting to think about trees as being a public good, but the palm tree, in particular being one that doesn't just message L.A. as a kind of semi-tropical paradise, but also as Mary Pickford said, it's very good for window shopping from the CD or car, because the tree trunks aren't that robust. So if you're driving down some boulevard, you can see all the great stuff because the palm tree is so narrow.
和名人们开始认为树木是一种公共物品，但棕榈树尤其如此，它不仅向外界传达了洛杉矶半热带天堂的信息，而且正如玛丽·皮克福德所说，它非常适合从汽车里进行橱窗购物，因为树干不是那么粗壮。所以如果你沿着某条大道开车，你可以看到所有好东西，因为棕榈树太窄了。
So Los Angeles was also re-zoned in the 1930s to become a single family city. Los Angeles in order to sort of not pacify and not suck up, but to sort of remake itself from the image of the FHA decided that all new single family homes had to come with a front and a side yard. So you start to create a lot of space around them. Los Angeles really starts to hate the idea of density. And so when you have this type of sprawling, not very dense city, how is the shade distributed? Unevenly. Shade is distributed to people who can afford it.
因此，洛杉矶在 20 世纪 30 年代也被重新区划为单一家庭城市。洛杉矶为了不进行安抚和吸纳，而是为了根据 FHA 的形象重塑自己，决定所有新建的单户住宅都必须配有前院和侧院。所以你开始在它们周围创造出很多空间。洛杉矶非常讨厌密度的概念。因此，当你拥有这种蔓延的、密度不高的城市时，树荫是如何分配的呢？不均匀。树荫分配给那些买得起的人。
If you go into these neighborhoods that were laid out to be wealthy residential enclaves, you have very wide sidewalks and the strip of grass where you can tree plant, which is called the parkway, becomes four or five, maybe even ten feet wide. And when you have these wider parkways, you have a greater space to plant a bigger, thicker, leafier tree. So, the parkway is the area between the sidewalk and the road. Correct. And there's going to be pretty wide and therefore have trees with them.
如果你走进这些被规划为富裕住宅区的街区，你会发现非常宽的人行道和可以植树的草带（被称为公园林荫带），宽度达到四、五英尺，甚至十英尺宽。当你拥有这些更宽的林荫带时，你就有更大的空间来种植更大、更厚、叶子更多的树。所以，林荫带是人行道和道路之间的区域。没错。而且它会相当宽，因此上面有树木。
Correct. In other neighborhoods that have been redlined, that were designed as sort of worker housing that were meant to sort of jam people in together, you don't have these kinds of wide residential sidewalks instead of what you have are very narrow sidewalks because these neighborhoods are designed to facilitate automobile passage. So if you have a narrow sidewalk, you don't really have the space to plant a thick leafy tree. Furthermore, it's been incumbent upon property owners and renters to maintain this sort
没错。在其他被划为红线区的街区，这些街区最初被设计为工人住房，旨在将人们挤在一起，你不会有这种宽阔的住宅人行道，相反，你拥有的是非常狭窄的人行道，因为这些街区旨在方便汽车通行。因此，如果你有人行道很窄，你真的没有空间种植茂密的树木。此外，物业业主和租户有责任维护林荫带这种
of semi-public space of the parkway. You would think that in a city, whatever's on the sidewalk, whatever's outside of the property line would be managed by the city. That has not historically been the case in Los Angeles. It's been incumbent upon property owners to water, trees, to maturity, and to maintain them. If there's a tree there, it's because someone has taken it upon themselves to water it to maturity and to care for it. So each part of that process, the design of where the sidewalk is relative to the street, the fact that a person of wealth could plant and maintain a tree, all these things cause more uneven distribution of shade trees. That's right. And I would also add that in some neighborhoods, I'm thinking about a neighborhood called Hancock Park, which is a flat neighborhood, landlocked in the center
半公共空间。你可能会认为，在一座城市里，人行道上的任何东西，物业线以外的任何东西都应该由城市管理。洛杉矶历史上并非如此。业主有责任为树木浇水直至其成熟并对其进行维护.如果有树在那里，那是因为有人自己承担了为它浇水至成熟并照顾它的责任。所以这个过程的每一个部分，人行道相对于街道位置的设计，富有之人可以种植和维护树木这一事实，所有这些事情都导致了遮阴树木分布更加不均。没错。我还要补充一点，在某些街区，我想到了一个叫做汉考克公园的街区，这是一个平坦的街区，位于市中心内陆。
of the city. There is nothing about it that naturally lends itself over to being a lush, verdant, tree-fistuned paradise. But the neighborhood was developed as an exclusive, wealthy residential enclave. And when that happened, the power lines were underground. There is nothing in the way it is designed specifically to allow for tree growth. This is not the case in most of Los Angeles. So because of this lack of shade trees, there have been efforts to build in shade, especially around bus shelters, but it's been incredibly hard, according to your reporting. So like in your article, you talk about one bus shelter at Glaston Park. Can you tell me about that and why it was so hard to put shade there?
城市的中心。它没有任何自然条件使其成为一个郁郁葱葱、绿树成荫的天堂。但该社区被开发为一个独特的富裕住宅区。当这种情况发生时，电力线在地下。它的设计中没有任何东西专门允许树木生长。洛杉矶大部分地区并非如此。因此，由于缺乏遮阳树，人们一直在努力建造遮阴设施，尤其是在公交候车亭周围，但据你的报道，这非常困难。比如在你的文章中，你谈到了格拉斯顿公园的一个公交候车亭。你能告诉我那件事以及为什么在那里放置阴影那么难吗？
It was hard because shade is a tripwire. Okay. In the instance of the Glaston Park Transit Island, you had a concern neighborhood resident, and a neighborhood activist maybe you'll call them a homeowner, who wanted to throw just a simple bus shelter over a space where she saw people naturally congregating. She ended up talking to an architect who said, let's not do a regular bus shelter, let's throw some big shade sales in here.
这很难，因为阴影是一个触发点。好吧。以格拉斯顿公园公交岛为例，有一位热心的社区居民和一位社区活动家（也许你可以称他们为房主），他们想在一个她看到人们自然聚集的地方搭建一个简单的公交候车亭。她最后跟一个建筑师谈过，建筑师说，咱们别做普通的公交候车亭了，咱们在这里扔几个大的遮阳帆吧。
And when that happens, you have to start thinking about, how are we going to fix these shade sales to the ground? And when that happens, you have to start thinking about how are we going to fix these shade sales to the ground. And when that happens, you have to start thinking about what's underneath the ground. And you have water mains, you have underground utilities, in order to upgrade a sidewalk or a transit island, you then have to start honoring newer regulations like the Americans with disabilities act, so then you have to start making curb cuts to make it wheelchair accessible. So you have to take care of all these other things before you can decide to do this very lightweight, sort of low res fix.
当这种情况发生时，你必须开始考虑，我们将如何把这些遮阳帆固定在地面上？当这种情况发生时，你必须开始考虑我们将如何把这些遮阳帆固定在地面上。当这种情况发生时，你必须开始考虑地下有什么。你有水管、地下公用设施，为了升级人行道或公交岛，你必须开始遵守更新的法规，比如《美国残疾人法案》，然后你必须开始做路缘坡道以使其适合轮椅通行。所以你必须处理好所有这些其他事情，才能决定做这种非常轻量级的、低分辨率的修复。
Right. The sort of the enemies of shade are not always bad guys. In this case, ADA compliance is not a bad guy. No. Yeah, like curb cuts, not a bad guy. No. Like all these things are not bad. You know, it's not just sort of around sidewalks. Um, LA doesn't have a lot of
没错。阴影的敌人并不总是坏人。在这种情况下，ADA 合规性并不是坏人。不。是的，就像路缘坡道一样，不是坏人。不。所有这些事情都不是坏事。你知道，这不仅仅是人行道周围的问题。嗯，洛杉矶没有多少
shaden at city parks either. So why is that? Why was this never considered valuable? It wouldn't go as so far as to say it was never considered valuable. Mm-hmm. Because I'm thinking about a park downtown called Purshing Square. That up until the 1950s was a tropical paradise. It was incredibly shady. It was meant for people to kind of hang out and shoot the breeze. And after a while, the business elite in the neighborhood decided, first of all, to install underground parking, which gets rid of the whole root system. So you can no longer plant thicker, denser tree canopy. And part of the reason why Pershing Square
城市公园里也有树荫。这是为什么？为什么这从未被认为是有价值的？我不会走那么远说它从来没有被认为是有价值的。嗯哼。因为我想到了市中心的一个叫做潘兴广场的公园。直到 20 世纪 50 年代，这里还是一个热带天堂。它非常阴凉。它是为了让人闲逛和聊天而设计的。过了一会儿，该社区的商业精英们决定，首先，安装地下停车场，这破坏了整个根系。所以你不能再种植更厚、更密的树冠了。潘兴广场之所以被改造并缩减树冠的部分原因
was redeveloped in Shornhub its tree canopy is because Los Angeles is a city where residents are worried about crime. A city where residents are worried about homelessness. As I was working on this story, I came across multiple instances where LAPD had installed pole cameras in parks or in public housing projects. And I'd been told about something called crime prevention
是因为洛杉矶是一个居民对犯罪感到担忧的城市。一个居民对无家可归者感到担忧的城市。在我写这个故事的时候，我遇到了多起洛杉矶警察局在公园或公共住房项目中安装杆式摄像头的案例。我被告知了一些叫做通过环境设计预防犯罪的概念，这个想法是我们需要提高公共空间的能见度。你可以在谷歌街景上回顾五、六年、七年。你可以看到随着时间的推移，当杆式摄像头竖起来时，一棵成熟的街道树就会倒下。所以所有这些选择性压力让其他事情变得更重要。你知道，就像它一样，无论它是，我称之为某种程度上对犯罪预防的幻觉。
through environmental design, which is this idea that we need to have increased visibility in public spaces. And you can go on Google Street View and go back five, six, seven years. And you can see over time, when a pole camera goes up, a mature street tree goes down. So there's all these selective pressures where other things are just more important. You know, like it, whether it's, I would call it somewhat the illusion of crime prevention.
正确。没有人告诉我它实际上能防止犯罪。侦探告诉我的是，它帮助警察抓获和起诉罪犯。不是说它能阻止他们。然后这种对地下停车场的偏爱，使得地下变浅，因此你只能种植那些具有球状根系的树木
Correct. No one told me that it actually prevents crime. What is detective told me was that it helps the police catch and prosecute criminals. Not that it stops them. And then this preference for this underground parking, which makes shallow ground, which, therefore, you can only have trees that have ball root systems
比如棕榈树。正确。感觉好像一切都在与之对抗，尤其是在这座城市。那么你如何看待如何平衡这些不同的因素及其在城市环境中的价值呢？问得好。
like palm trees. Correct. It just seems like everything is working against it, especially in this city. And so how do you think about how to balance these, you know, these different factors and their value in an urban setting? Great question.
有几种方法可以考虑这一点。我提到在洛杉矶，是房主和居民负责行道树的维护和培育。为什么非要这样呢？为什么这座城市不决定建设公共城市森林呢？为什么这不是一种价值？你可能还会考虑密度问题。我和一位建筑师谈过，他告诉我说，最大化楼层空间是关键，这意味着如果你只有这么大的空间可以利用，哪个开发商会说，让我们实际上腾出一些楼层空间来做一个拱廊或门廊。这很难推销。那么为什么城市不适当地激励开发商在物业线后面创建这些类似于公共的遮阴环境，与人行道相连呢？只是种树怎么样？我的意思是，洛杉矶在总体上增加树冠方面在做些什么？
There are a few ways to think about this. I mentioned that in Los Angeles, it's homeowners and residents who are responsible for the maintenance and cultivation of street trees. Why does it have to be that way? Why doesn't the city decide that a public urban forest? Why isn't that a value? You might also think about the question of density. I spoke to an architect, and what he told me is that maximizing floor space is the name
这个城市正试图种植更多的树木。该市的目标是在未来几年内种植 90,000 棵树。我并不充分相信该市认识到了种植 90,000 棵树的基础设施挑战，因为正如我们一直在讨论的那样，你可以种树的空间是有限的。当你遇到诸如狭窄的人行道、架空电线，甚至是限制或禁止在距离车道 45 英尺以内种植行道树的法规时，说实话，这几乎涵盖了整个洛杉矶。这让我觉得这座城市并没有理解种植 90,000 棵树所需要对街道进行的完全彻底的重新构想。
of the game, which means if you only have so much space to work with, which developer is going to say, let's actually carve out some of our floor space to make an arcade or a portico. That's a tough sell. So why doesn't the city properly incentivize developers to create these sort of semi-public shaded environments behind the property line that are contiguous with the sidewalk? What about just planting trees? I mean, what is LA doing about just adding to the canopy in general?
我们在节目中讨论了很多非正规城市主义和某种干预措施。人们可以在没有许可的情况下安装雨伞和遮阳篷来解决这种问题，只在他们自己的街区里。你发现有人这样做的证据了吗？当这种情况发生时，反应是什么？人们一直在这样做。特别是我要补充的是，在拉丁裔社区。有一个名叫詹姆斯·罗哈斯（James Rojas）的城市规划师，他写关于拉丁裔城市主义的文章，他有一个非常引人注目的理论，即洛杉矶的拉丁裔居民知道如何利用树荫。他带领这些精彩的徒步之旅，他会指出
The city is trying to plant more trees. The city has a goal of planting 90,000 trees in the next few years. I am not sufficiently convinced that the city recognizes the infrastructural challenge to planting 90,000 trees because as we've been talking about the space in which you can plant a tree is limited. When you have things like an aeroside walk or overhead power lines or even regulations that limit or prohibit the planting of a street tree within 45 feet of a driveway, which let's be real, that's practically all of Los Angeles. That makes me think that the city is not understanding the complete wholesale reimagining of the
连接在小巷中两个车库之间的遮阳帆，供孩子们玩耍，因为在树荫下更舒服，或者他会指出这些精心布置的前院，在那里你可以看到蓝色的聚酯顶布穿梭于空间中，或者也许有些异国情调的树木溢出到街道上。嗯，这听起来对我很棒，但给我的印象是，这座城市并不总是以同样的方式看待事物。我发现的是，在私人领域，这些事情是被容忍的。当他们踏入公共场合并踏上人行道时，事情就变得更加复杂了。我写了一篇关于草根遮阳棚的文章
street that's needed in order to plant 90,000 trees. So we've talked a lot about informal urbanism in the show, and sort of interventions. People could install umbrellas and canopies without permission to fix this kind of problem just in their own neighborhood. Did you find evidence of people doing this and what is the reaction when this happens? People do it all the time. Particularly I will add in Latino neighborhoods. There's an urbanist named James Rojas who writes about Latino urbanism And he has a pretty compelling theory that Latino residents of Los Angeles know how to use the shade And he leads these wonderful walking tours where he'll point out
位于洛杉矶河附近的赛普拉斯公园社区的菲格罗亚街和 26 大道交汇处。一个名叫托尼·科内霍（Tony Conejo）的理发师不承认是他制作了这个非常棒的、由工字钢、大焦油布和几个公交长椅制成的遮阳棚，但他告诉我，他认识到人们在等公交车时需要一些保护。托尼或其他什么人不得不拆除这个草根公交候车亭
Shade sales that have been connected between two garages in an alleyway for kids to play in because it's more comfortable under the shade Or he'll point out these elaborate front yards where you have blue polytops just strung across a space or maybe exotic trees that are sort of overflowing into the street. Well, that sounds great to me, but I get the impression that the city doesn't always see things the same way. What I did find is that in the private realm, those things are tolerated. When they step into the public and when they step onto the sidewalk, things become more complicated. I write about a grassroots shade shelter
因为它阻碍了公共通行权。该市每年处理 16,000 起公共通行权受阻事件。如果业主和居民不害怕城市会以罚款威胁他们，也许我们会看到更多的草根城市主义。我认为把阴影视为政治不平等问题是非常令人惊讶的。我想这会让很多人感到惊讶。请告诉我你对这一点的觉悟，以及你是如何说服人们的，并最好地阐述当你想到城市中的阴影时，你希望人们思考什么。尊重那些买不起空调咖啡馆或在天气太热时叫车的人。
on Figueroa and Avenue 26 in the Cyprus Park neighborhood near the LA River. And a barber named Tony Conejo would not admit that it was he who made this really great, fantastic shade shelter made out of like an Ibeam and a great tarp and a couple bus benches, but he told me that he recognized the need for people when they're waiting for the bus just to have some protection. Tony or someone had to take down this grassroots bus shelter
在我看来，阴影是一种理解，即世界正在发生变化，我们希望保护那些无法保护自己的最弱势公民。而且呆在阴影里也更好，阴影里更凉爽。我总是走在街道阴凉的一侧，在阴凉处更容易看清。你知道，我和一位科学家谈过，他说直射阳光就像你做口腔手术时得到的那种光。那并不愉快。不，斑驳的光线更像是读书。
because it was an obstruction in the public right of way. The city processes 16,000 obstructions in the public right of way every year. If property owners, if residents did not fear that the city would come after them threatening them with fines, perhaps we would see more grassroots urbanism. I think it's pretty surprising to think of shade as a political inequity issue. I think it surprises a lot of people. Tell me about your awakening of this and convincing people of it and just make your best case for what it is that you want people to think about when they think about shade in the city. respect for people who can't afford to duck into an air-conditioned cafe or a lift when it gets too hot.
所以我希望我的城市帮我读书。我不想做口腔手术。是的，谢谢你来。我很感激。是的，谢谢邀请我，罗曼。萨姆·布洛克的文章名为《阴影出现在……中》。接下来，随着最热的城市开始认识到树木和阴影的重要性，建筑师们正在绘制越来越多的树木。
Shade is to me an understanding that the world is changing and we want to protect citizens, the most vulnerable citizens who can't protect themselves. And it's also just nicer to be in the shade, it's cooler in the shade. I always walk on the shady side of the street, it's easier to see in the shade. You know, I spoke to a scientist who said that direct sunlight is the kind of light that you have when you perform oral surgery. That's not pleasant. No, dappled light is more like reading a book.
在他们的建筑方案中到处都是，几乎达到滑稽数量的树木，甚至在建筑本身上也是如此。我和库尔特在这之后会谈论这个。所以，在我采访了萨姆·布洛克关于城市阴影的问题后，我们联系了一群景观建筑师，他们每个人都说解决方案很简单，我们需要在城市里规划更多的树木。如果你看建筑渲染图，你会注意到的一件事
So I want my city to help me read a book. I don't want to perform a world surgery. Yeah, thanks for coming in. I appreciate that. Yeah, thanks for having me, Roman. Sam Bloch's article called, shade appeared in places during. Up next, as the hottest cities are beginning to recognize the importance of trees and shade, architects are drawing more and more trees.
拟建建筑的四周到处都是树木，因为这样看起来很美，并推销了这样一个未来基地是混凝土城市中的绿洲的想法。更进一步，越来越多的渲染图实际上在建筑物本身上展示了大树和灌木。就像摩天大楼上的整个垂直森林。
All over their building proposals, almost a comical amount of trees, even on the building itself. Kurt and I talk about that after this. So, after I interviewed Sam Block about Shaden cities, we reached out to a bunch of landscape architects, and each of them said that the solution was pretty simple, that we need to plan more trees in cities. And one thing that you notice, if you look at architectural renderings
库尔特·库尔斯塔德（Kurt Kulstad）是让我意识到这一趋势的人，他在我的工作室里和我一起讨论这个话题。那么，你是什么时候第一次注意到树木在渲染图中淹没摩天大楼的呢？我的意思是，十年前我在建筑学院时绝对不是这样的。我想说这比那更近。在 2010 年代，我开始注意到
of proposed buildings, is that there are trees everywhere in the drawings because it looks pretty and it sells the idea of this future site being an oasis in the concrete city. And to take it a step further, more and more renderings feature big trees and shrubs actually on building themselves. Like whole vertical forests on skyscrapers.
越来越多的这些日益荒谬的渲染图，树木到处都是，而且盛开着美丽的花朵。而且，你知道，建筑师们有一种长期传统，即通过他们的渲染图来突破界限。你会看到很多非常干净的线条。你可能看不到阳台上难看的栏杆，那些最终会存在的东西，但这种“我们要在所有东西上都放上绿色植物，并假设没问题，人们会买单”的态度。我的意思是，它已经到了荒谬的地步。这真的是推销形象的想法
And Kurt Kulstad was the person who made me aware of this trend and he's in the studio with me to talk about it. So when did you first notice trees just overrunning skyscrapers and renderings? I mean, it definitely wasn't the thing when I was an architecture school a decade ago. I would say it was more recent than that. During the 2010s, I started to notice
还是你认为这有点像这种绿洗的联想，即在这样的建筑物上种树感觉很环保？哦，是的，我的意思是，这就是它的伟大之处，对吧？你可以把它卖给环保主义者，就像看看我们的建筑字面意义上有多绿。当然，你可以把它卖给人们
more and more of these increasingly absurd renderings, where the trees were just kind of everywhere and they were beautiful and bloom. And, you know, architects have a long tradition of kind of pushing the edges with their renderings. You'll see like a lot of really clean lines. You might not see the ugly railings on balconies, the things that are going to be there in the end, but this kind of like, we're just going to put greenery on everything and just assume that's fine and people will buy that. I mean, it just kind of got to the point of being absurd. Is it really this idea of selling an image
因为他们会觉得，哇，我要在 24 层，但我周围仍然会有这种郁郁葱葱的绿草。这也有道理，对吧？我的意思是，你可以帮助支持生态系统，你可以帮助过滤空气，至少可以为居民提供一些树荫。在高处种植绿植是有论据的。没错。总的问题是人们没有意识到这是多么具有挑战性。没错。那么在建筑物上放置非常大的绿植有什么挑战呢？
or do you think it's like a little bit of this greenwashing association that it feels environmental to have trees on buildings like that? Oh yeah, I mean, that's the great thing about it, right? You can sort of sell it to environmentalists, like look how literally green our building is. And of course, you can sell it to people
所以这方面的头号挑战就是能够物理支撑这些绿色植物，对吧？就像，它有多重？是的，树木很重。建筑师必须同时为主动荷载和被动荷载进行设计，主动荷载是人等东西，被动荷载是降雪等。基本上放置这些又大又重的树木
because they're like, wow, I'm gonna be on the 24th floor but I'm still gonna have this kind of like lush greenery surrounding me. There's something to that too, right? I mean, like you can help bolster ecosystems, you can help filter air, you can provide some shade at least for the residents. There are arguments for putting greenery up high. Right. The problem in general is just that people don't realize how challenging it is. Right. And so what are the challenges of putting really big greenery on a building?
可以使被动负载要求翻倍或三倍。最后你不得不引入所有这些额外的结构。最重要的是，这不仅是为了支撑树木的结构，也是为了支撑两三英尺厚的土壤来支撑树木。我的意思是，它只是堆叠在灌溉系统中。将这些东西吊装上去
So the kind of number one challenge of this is just being able to support that greenery physically, right? So like, like, how's your heavy? Yeah, trees are heavy. And like, architects have to design for both active and passive loads, active loads being things like people, and passive loads being like, you know, snowfall. And basically putting like these big, heavy trees
首先。我的意思是，清单很长。没错。它只是被动的吗？我的意思是，这给我的印象是高海拔地区的树木实际上有点主动，因为它们在风中吹动并且会移动。这是你需要考虑的事情吗？
can like double or triple the passive load requirements. So you end up having to bring in all this extra structure. And on top of that, that's not just structured to support the trees, that's also structured to support two or three feet of soil to support the tree. I mean, it just kind of stacks in their irrigation systems. There's the hoisting up of these things
我的意思是，我不知道他们是否在为此做侧向载荷计算，但风对这些东西的影响绝对是一个因素，对吧？所以你把这些东西弄得很高。树木成林是有原因的，对吧？就像它们喜欢被其他树木包围一样。其他树木有助于防止它们被风吹倒。
in the first place. I mean, the list is locked. Right. Is it only passive? I mean, it strikes me that trees at high altitude are actually kind of active because they blow in the wind and they move. Is that something you have to account for?
因此，高海拔地区的大风会打断光合作用过程，并给没有为该环境而生和养育的东西带来各种各样的问题。最重要的是，在许多这样的塔楼中，它们在所有两侧都显示出相同的绿色植物，这看起来很可爱。现实运作方式不同，太阳升起又落下，所以如果你有一栋朝北立面的建筑，
I mean, I don't know if they're doing sort of lateral load calculations for that, but definitely the impact of wind on these things is a factor, right? So you get these things up high. Trees like forests for a reason, right? Like they like to be surrounded by other trees. And other trees help keep them from like blowing down.
你可能会遇到从未见过的树木任何阳光。因此，这种对所有各方的平等对待让人感觉有点生硬，而且不是很可持续。因此，绿化看起来很环保，但首要问题是，你必须投入所有这些额外的材料，如混凝土和钢材，才能使这些绿化在一栋大建筑物上变得可行。所以这是如果这一切成为现实的话的缺点之一。我认为最根本的事情是大多数时候它不是现实。
So the high winds at higher altitudes can interrupt photosynthetic processes and just kind of cause different issues for you know that you know wasn't born and bred for that environment. And on top of that too, in a lot of these towers they show kind of equal greenery on all sides and that looks lovely. Reality works differently, like the sun rises, it sets, and so if you've got a building, for example, with a North facing facade,
对，对。其中很多都没有建造。这些是一些概念渲染图，旨在吸引人们对建筑事务所的兴趣，是为比赛设计的，而不是为了建造。所以确实建造了不同程度的成功和失败。其中一个典型例子确实建成了，被称为垂直森林，位于米兰，是一对双子塔。它们满足了我们一直在讨论的许多标准。它们本质上在各个方向都有相同的绿化。非常郁郁葱葱。他们建造了这些，对吧？
you might have trees that never see any sunlight. So this kind of equal treatment on all sides makes it seem a little artificial and not very sustainable. So the greenery looks environmental, but the first problem is you have to put all these extra materials concrete and steel to make this greenery viable on top of a big building. So that's sort of one of the drawbacks of if any of this was ever a reality. I think the fundamental thing is most of the time it isn't a reality.
他们把树吊了上去，看起来还不错，而且似乎正在发挥作用。但是，你知道，他们在施工中也遇到了很多问题。有很多施工延误，以及弄清楚我们如何灌溉这些东西并适应这些载荷。其中一些是可以预测的。其中一些有点特定于这栋建筑必须做比许多建筑更多的事情这一事实。同一家公司此后继续为其他城市设计了其他示例
Right, right. A lot of these don't get built. There's sort of concept renderings that kind of get people interested in an architecture firm, you know, designed for competitions and not for being built. So do get built with sort of various degrees of success and failure. And one of the classic examples of one of these that really did get built is called the Vertical Forest and it's in Milan and it's a pair of towers. They meet a lot of the criteria we've been talking about. They essentially have kind of equal greenery on all sides. It's really lush. They made these things, right?
它们看起来都一样。它们看起来就像是，嘿，我们有这个模型，我们要把它应用到所有这些不同的地方。但当我看着他们的渲染图时，总是让我崩溃的一件事是，你会看到建筑侧面有很多树木，然后他们会描绘下面周围的广场。会有几棵树。我禁不住在想，你知道，如果你真的想走向全绿色，最简单的方法就是在地面上增加更多的树木。这让人不禁想知道，这到底有什么目的？是美学吗？
And they hoisted the trees up, and it doesn't look bad, and it seems to be sort of working. But, you know, they encountered a lot of issues too in construction. There were a lot of construction delays and sort of figuring out how are we going to irrigate these things and accommodate these loads. Some of those are predictable. Some of those are kind of specific to the fact that this building had to do more than a lot of buildings have to do. That same firm has since gone on to design other examples for other
仅仅是为了居民吗？我的意思是，如果他们试图服务于公共利益、过滤空气、做所有这些事情，他们可以把下层空间的绿化真正塞满，这可能是一个非常好的便利设施。没错。这也是你让我意识到的有趣的副作用之一，也就是，在建筑物上种树是建筑的前沿，而他们放弃的是在每个人都可以使用的地面上种树。有趣的是，这让人觉得建筑师在某种程度上有点
cities. They all kind of look the same. They sort of look like, hey, we've got this model and we're going to kind of apply in all these different places. But one of the things that always cracks me up when I'm looking at their renderings is you'll see all these trees up on the sides of the buildings and then they'll depict the plaza surrounding it below. And they'll be like a couple of trees. And I can't help but think, you know, if you really want to go all green, the easiest way to do that would be to just add more trees on the ground. And so it makes you wonder, like, what is really the purpose? Is it aesthetic?
走得太远了。我们过去认为绿色屋顶很好，绿色屋顶很好。它们通常是薄薄的绿色植物层，具有吸收热量和转化氧气等特定功能，而且制作或维护不需要做太多工作，也就是所谓的广泛绿化，也就是薄薄的一层。苔藓和草。就像多肉植物一样。
Is it just for the residents? I mean, if they were trying to sort of serve the public good, filter air, do all these things, they could just really pack in the greenery on the space below, and it would be potentially a really nice eminuity. Right. That's one of the interesting side effects that actually you made me aware of as well, which is like, you know, putting trees on a building is like on the vanguard of architecture, and what they abandon in this is just putting trees on the ground where everyone can use them. And what's also interesting is that it feels a little bit like architects jump the
你真的不用太担心它。是的，它或多或少能自己照顾自己。你可能需要一些灌溉。重量要求大大降低。所以这就像他们从一个好的地方开始说，好吧，让我们增加这些绿色植物层，它将对城市、建筑和所有这些事情带来真正的益处。
shark at some point. We used to have this idea of green roofs are good and green roofs are good. Often they're kind of thin layers of greenery and they serve certain functions like absorbing heat and converting oxygen and they don't take nearly as much work to make or maintain just kind of this what's called extensive greenery, which is to say like sort of thin. Mouses and grasses. It's like a succulent.
而且超级愉快。如果你去过有绿色屋顶的高档办公楼，在上面有那个感觉太棒了。我也见过非常漂亮的绿色墙壁，那种很薄的，不过度的。然后在某个时候，美学接管了一切，感觉就像，嗯，这很好，但在我用来向开发商和其他任何人推销的这东西的图纸上看起来并不是很好。
You don't really have to worry about it too much. Yeah, like it more or less takes care of itself. You might need some irrigation. The weight requirements are far reduced. And so it's like they started in this good place of saying like, well, let's add these layers of greenery and it will be a real benefit to the city, to the building, and all these things.
一旦你种了一棵树，你知道的，你必须在那里放一整片森林，你必须拥有整个垂直森林，对吧？但我真的很着迷于这样一个副作用：让你的垂直摩天大楼森林脱颖而出的方法是移走底部的所有树木。哦，是的。而这正是它发挥最大作用并解决萨姆指出的问题的地方，即各处遮阴的不平等。而当我们谈到城市中的阴影问题时，我们得出的简单结论是更多的树木。但像大多数事情一样，地点，地点，地点。
And it's super pleasant. If you've ever been in like a fancy office building that has a green roof, it's great to have that on top there. And I've seen really nice green walls like that too, sort of just kind of thin, not over done. And then at some point, it's like the aesthetic just kind of took over and it's like, well, that's nice and all, but it doesn't really look great in my drawing of this thing that I'm using to sell to like developers and whoever else.
真的很重要。是的，就是这样。如果这些设计者不仅在他们的建筑上种树，而且在他们的建筑周围以及每一个地方都种树，我会更相信他们的意图。可用空间，因为那些是最容易安装或种植的。它们将是最容易照料的。它们可能会带来一些公共利益，或者即使你在某种庭院里，至少它们可以为正在建设的社区服务。当他们省略地面上的树木并将它们高高堆叠起来以使他们的建筑真正脱颖而出时，确实如此。感觉有点像他们倾向于这种几乎反阴影的立场。
And then once you've got one tree, you know, you've got to put a whole forest up there, you've got to have a whole vertical forest, right? But I'm really intrigued by this side effect of like the way to make your vertical skyscraper forest stand out is to take away all the trees at the base. Oh, yeah. And that's where it would do the most good and solve this problem that Sam has pointed out, the lack of equity when it comes to shade in places. And whereas I think the simple conclusion that we come to when it comes to the issue of
我们要把阴影留给住在这里的这些富有公民。我们已经成功私有化了阴影。我们已经成功私有化了阴影。我深入研究的一件事，虽然我不是专家，但我研究的事情之一就是这些树木究竟能带来多少好处，
shade in cities is more trees. But like most things, location, location, location. Yeah. Is really important. Yeah. And that's the thing. I would trust the intentions of these designers more if they were putting trees both on their buildings, but also all around their buildings and every
城市里的阴凉更多来自树木。但就像大多数事情一样，地段、地段、地段。是的。这真的很重要。是的。就是这样。如果这些设计师不仅在建筑物上种树，还在建筑物的周围以及每一个
available space because those are going to be the easiest to install or plant. They're going to be the easiest to take care of. They're going to serve some public benefits potentially, or even if you're in sort of a courtyard, at least they serve the community that is being built for. And when they omit those trees on the ground and stack them all up high to make their building really stand out, it does. It feels kind of like they're leaning into this almost anti-shade stance.
可用的空间都种上树，我会更相信他们的意图，因为这些树最容易种植或栽种。它们最容易照料。它们可能会带来一些公共利益，或者即使你在某种庭院里，至少它们能为正在建设的社区服务。当他们忽略地面的树木，把它们高高堆砌起来让自己的建筑脱颖而出时，确实如此。感觉他们几乎是在倾向于这种几乎反树荫的立场。
We are going to reserve the shade for these rich citizens who live here. We've privatized shade. We have successfully privatized shade. And one of the things that I've dug into a little bit, and I'm not an expert on, but one of the things that I've looked at is this question of how much good do these trees do,
我们要为住在这里的这些富裕市民保留树荫。我们将树荫私有化了。我们成功地将树荫私有化了。我深入研究过的一件事，虽然我不是这方面的专家，但我研究过的问题之一是，这些树木到底能发挥多大的作用，
because it is good to add greenery to cities. Yeah, absolutely. And by some rough math, so don't hold me to it. It looks like, for example, in one of these projects, the greenery that they've encased this giant building in offsets the effective carbon footprint of heating a half dozen homes for a year. And that's good, but it doesn't, you know, if you're thinking about carbon neutrality or even having something that's carbon negative, just installing those trees and creating
因为在城市中增加绿化是件好事。是的，绝对如此。粗略计算一下，别太较真，比如在其中一个项目中，他们用绿化包裹了这座巨型建筑，这抵消了半打家庭一年的取暖有效碳足迹。这很好，但它并不能——你知道的，如果你在考虑碳中和甚至碳负排放，仅仅安装这些树木并创造
all the structure for them might take up just as much carbon as they're offsetting. And so the idea that if you clad your skyscraper and trees it's going to actually make the building greener is going to be really context dependent. It might someday in some cases, but in a lot of cases it's offset by all the work you have to put into it in the first place. Totally. Architects have good intentions in general, and I think architects tend to want to solve every problem they can, including problems that aren't within their purview, essentially. I'm sure a lot of architects say to themselves, this is great. I'm putting greenery up on buildings, and I just think it would be helpful if there was some more self-examination around the question of, you know, how is this going to work as a system beyond my particular building? It's great if you're providing habitats and shade and oxygen conversion on your building,
支撑它们的整个结构，所消耗的碳可能与它们抵消的碳一样多。因此，如果以为给摩天大楼披上树木就能真正让建筑变得更环保，那将非常取决于具体情境。有时在某些情况下或许可以，但在许多情况下，它会被你一开始为此投入的所有工作所抵消。完全同意。总体而言，建筑师们的初衷是好的，我认为建筑师往往倾向于解决他们能解决的每一个问题，包括本质上不在他们职责范围内的问题。我确信很多建筑师都会对自己说，这太棒了。我正在建筑物上增加绿化，我只是觉得，如果能围绕这样一个问题进行更多自我反省，将会很有帮助：除了我这栋特定的建筑之外，作为一个系统，这将会如何运作？如果你能在建筑上提供栖息地、阴凉和氧气转化，那固然很好，
but how is that going to interact with the city? And what is the net effect of what you're doing? Okay, well, I'm so glad that you made me aware of this and you wrote an article about this on the site a long time ago. Yeah, I've written a few and there's somewhat snarky in their headlines. I kind of have like a little axe to grind with this. Call out. Okay, that's cool.
但这将如何与城市产生互动？你所做的事情的净效应是什么？好的，我很高兴你让我意识到了这一点，你很久以前就在网站上写过关于这的文章。是的，我写过几篇，它们的标题有点讽刺意味。我对这件事确实有点个人偏见。点名批评。好吧，这很酷。
We can check it out on the website. It's 9-9-PI-DOT-OR. 99% Invisible Was Produced This Week by Chris Baroube and Kurt Colestead, Music by Sean Riel, Katie Mingle is the senior producer, thrust the team in senior editor Delaney Hong, Sheree Fusef, A Reach Offensive, Emmett Fitzgerald Vivian-Lay, Sophia Klatsker, Joe Rosenberg, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7KALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California 99% of visible is a member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting.
我们可以在网站上查看它。网址是 99pi.org。《99% Invisible》本周由克里斯·巴鲁贝（Chris Baroube）和库尔特·科尔斯特德（Kurt Colestead）制作，音乐由肖恩·里尔（Sean Riel）创作，凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）担任高级制作人，团队成员还包括高级编辑德兰妮·洪（Delaney Hong）、谢丽·菲塞夫（Sheree Fusef）、阿雷奇·奥芬西夫（A Reach Offensive）、埃mett·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、维维安·莱（Vivian-Lay）、索菲亚·克拉茨克（Sophia Klatsker）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）以及我罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。我们是旧金山 91.7KALW 的一个项目，在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心的广播街（Radio Row）制作。《99% Invisible》是 PRX 旗下 Radiotopia 的成员，这是一个由播客界最具创新性的节目组成的坚决独立的集合。
Find them all at radiotopia.fm You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI or one Instagram and read it too. But we're throwing a lot more shade at 99PI.org. Radio Topia. From PRX. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请在 radiotopia.fm 上查找所有这些节目。你可以在 Facebook 上找到本节目并参与讨论。你可以在 Twitter 上@我 Roman Mars 以及节目 @99PI，也可以在 Instagram 和 Reddit 上找到我们。但我们在 99pi.org 上提供了更多的阴凉（谐音梗）。Radiotopia。来自 PRX。来自 PRX。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。